[Applause]
I know why you're happy we know we've
we've made it through the rain not us
personally or in LA of course but we
weathered in this country hurricane
Harvey and an American Irma and now
we're back to worrying about shitstorm
Donald it's back to normal but hey
before we get to the politics let's try
to reach out the president has a new
grandson
and come on he's bald and always crying
and wetting himself but he's very happy
about the new baby so so yes there's
another Trump in the world and know
whether it was a to taya there's a
little bit of a scare when the baby
first came out he wasn't smirking so
anyway a lot of lot of terrifying things
going on in the world North Korea fired
another missile these [ __ ] are
not kidding around this was the longest
one all the way over Japan and
apparently Kim jong-un was very pleased
he awarded his his scientist North
Korea's highest honor lunch but the big
political news you see that Donald Trump
this week announced a breakthrough on
immigration the dreamers can stay and by
that mean he means they can't stay or
maybe they can stay as somebody else he
wants of this day he wants you to a wide
and by that he means get out
and we're building the wall and by that
he means we're repairing the fence I
mean he thinks he thinks he's being
bipartisan this is not bipartisan this
is bipolar this is
I don't know if he knows what he wants
today he said Selena Gomez has to go
back but her kidney can stay
[Applause]
no of course with Donald Trump it's
always personal you know he's fed up
with his own party because he doesn't
like Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan so
now he's like making nice with Schumer
and Pelosi again this week he wined and
dined Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
well they dined he wined and after the
meeting the Democrats put out a
statement that said we agreed with the
president to enshrine the protections of
daca into law and work out a package of
border security excluding the wall
that's how they that's how they remember
it that's not how Trump remembers me
what he remembers is we had cake there
was a fire truck it went rooms room and
then it was time for TV but it sure
looks like it had some effect on him
meeting with the Democrats I mean his
thinking about the dreamers seems to
have change because he tweeted something
that I said it was super supportive he
Donald Trump tweeted does anybody really
want to throw out good educated
accomplished young people and his
supporters said [ __ ] yes of course we do
we want to do it yesterday his base is
furious at him Breitbart calls him
amnesty Don now and Coulter is calling
for his impeachment even Hannity and
Rush Limbaugh turning on him the
deplorable 'he's really think this is
deplorable
there are former Trump fans all over the
internet who are burning their make
America great hats which is very scary
because it means they've discovered fire
tools could be next but one of trumps
fence issued him a very stern warning he
said mr. president don't forget who put
you there
and that's when Putin just laughed so
Trump you know he's had it up in this
political [ __ ] he went back this
week to the one thing he knows he could
definitely get done as president
visiting hurricane sites he went back to
Florida today for the third time there
like enough
he and the first lady served up food to
the victims or as Milania calls the
program meals on heels and she no I
could no Adi she dressed more sensibly
this time she was wearing a safari
jacket and no stroke
apparently she was disappointed when
they told us she was just going to be
looking at poor people not actually
hunting them but here's the most amazing
thing of all Ament all the destruction
in the path of that hurricane neither
Mara Lago nor Trump's estate and Saint
Martins nor any of his golf courses in
the path got damaged at all they all
escaped almost completely unscathed
which just goes to show something I have
always believed there is no God